ministre mes chers collègues ma question
porte sur le départ précipité du
gouvernement de la ministre de la santé
madame lizin a démissionné de son poste
pour reprendre pied levé la campagne de
benjamin griveaux dans les circonstances
que l'on sait cette démission intervient
au moment où la crise du cours navires
us fait son premier mort en france où la
réforme des retraites est quasiment dans
l'impasse et où l'hôpital public
traverse une crise profonde et durable
je regrette en particulier que les
mesures prises pour le personnel
soignant concerne essentiellement les
hôpitaux parisiens
il ya de l'incompréhension et de
l'étonnement
car être ministre du nouveau monde
n'empêche visiblement pas de faire
campagne pour les élections municipales
vous même monsieur le premier ministre
vous faites campagne war monsieur
darmana ministre d'action et des comptes
publics à tourcoing monsieur franck
risser ministre de la culture à
coulommiers
madame marianne chappaz secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et de la lutte
contre les discriminations dans le 14e
arrondissement
môssieur lecornu ministre chargé des
collectivités territoriales à vernon
madame darrieussecq secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre des armées à
mont-de-marsan et monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
un marché noir
doit-on comprendre que dans le nouveau
monde
on peut être ministre à temps partiel et
se présente à une élection tout en
annonçant à l'avancé que l'on ne siègera
pas comme maire dans ce contexte la
démission de la ministre de la santé
s'apparente encore plus à une désertion
alors pour quelle région madame busin
elle était obligée de démissionner du
gouvernement pour faire campagne à paris